most Americans will get a tax cut next
year under the plan Congress passed this
week but figuring out exactly how much
your family will save is tricky
Republicans say a typical family of four
earning 73 thousand dollars a year will
see taxes drop by more than two thousand
dollars but circumstances can vary
widely depending on factors like income
the number of children or where you live
Tony Duke ople set out to learn how the
legislation will affect some tax payers
Tony good morning good morning recent
polls suggest a sizable number of
Americans actually oppose this tax bill
but now that lawmakers have passed it we
wanted to see how folks will actually
fare so we asked households from three
different parts of the country to send
us their tax returns and that we had an
accountant calculate how things will
change for each of them without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the table as Republicans sent
the tax bill to the White House Marcy
George wondered if it would make a
difference in her house it didn't seem
as they were going along that it would
really affect someone like me a single
mother who rents a home in Cary North
Carolina her income last year as an
administrative assistant was a little
under $40,000 financially I struggle I
live paycheck to paycheck I make things
work I reject and rearrange but I we do
get by so will getting by get any easier
we brought her 2016 tax return to
Jeffery Levine a certified public
accountant at blue print wealth Alliance
on New York's Long Island if she were
your client what would you tell her I
got good news for you Marcy you're
getting more money back next year
he says she'll benefit from a doubling
of the child tax credit and based on her
returns last year he estimates a savings
of about thirteen hundred dollars in
taxes that would be more that I would be
seeing in each paycheck so that would be
a good thing
amber and Jason Edwards were also hoping
for some good news
you know I hope it alleviates you know
pressure on the middle class whether it
does or not I don't know I guess we'll
find out they're married homeowners with
no kids
in Providence Rhode Island as college
educators they took in more than 150
thousand dollars last year as they
worked to pay down their Stu
loans financially we're you know we're
doing okay we're certainly you know not
at the poverty level or anything of that
nature Jason who blogs about their
finances wanted to know how things would
change I actually think they would pay
tax on about $12,000 more of income but
because of the lower rates they actually
end up saving a little bit of money the
vine says the couple will switch to the
newly increased standard deduction which
means a simple of return with no
itemized deductions
he thinks they'd only I'm a little
surprised because well what you had said
initially you thought we were gonna have
a higher tax bill right they're not the
only ones Melissa and Lane Lev also
expressed concern about next year's
taxes I'm thinking they're gonna be
higher and by how much
I don't know if I could answer that I'm
just thinking they're gonna be higher
married with three children they own a
home in Fresno California
they opened a cycle studio last year and
Melissa is a pharmaceutical sales rep
their combined income in 2016 was around
$300,000 we were doing well enough to
take a risk and open up a small business
in our town it's definitely hard work
and definitely a lot of stress when when
we have you know so much of our worth on
the line so to speak Lane and Melissa
are from California very high income tax
state so there are a lot of people
worried oh my goodness this is this is
really gonna hurt me they thought it was
gonna be a big bill
I'm not surprised it actually is really
gonna help them though the vine says
their itemized deductions including
breaks for state and local taxes will be
much lower but they'll no longer be hit
with the alternative minimum tax and
will now qualify for child tax credits
when they didn't before overall he
estimates they'll be responsible for
nearly thirteen thousand dollars less in
taxes well that's good I like the sound
of that can I get the accountants number
after this so I mean so all three
families that we brought to you they're
all going to see a decrease in their
taxes every single one of those families
will have
more money in their pocket next year the
accounting Jeff Levine points out that
his calculations are only estimates and
he says everything could change in a few
years when many of these new provisions
expire for everybody but I think you
started a fight in the Edward deed you
know one thing some Republicans you may
recall were waving postcards suggesting
that filling out your taxes would be as
easy as filling out a postcard according
to that accountant not so much could be
calculated the phones are ringing in his
office I want to talk about the Edwards
family amber had a classic wife move
well what you say which was really
saying is you were wrong all right